ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
عميد الياس حنا ماذا تحقق روسيا بالسيطره
على سوليدار فيما لو صحت الروايه الروسيه
بهذا الشان
دار هي هدف مرحله باتجاه بخموت ولكن
القيمه الاستراتيجيه لسوليدار بالنسبه
للمكاسب او
الخسائر التي وقعت بين السوليدار وبموت
ومده الوقت يعني الحرب تدور على جبهه
مخموت منذ سته اشهر وعدد القتلى وهذا
الاستنزاف الكبير خاصه على المعركه هي
حصريه لقوات
تساعدها قوات من المظليين على مسافات
بعيده الهدف دائما هو تطويق بخموط قطع طرق
الامدادات عنها وبالتالي فتح الباب امام
التقدم باتجاه صلبينس
ااا كلمه تورس ولكن هذا الامر على الخريطه
سهل على التحليل والكتابه سهل ولكن يبقى
ما هي الكلفه يعني همم
هل سيكون هناك
استنزاف للقوات النخبه يعني دائما بيحارب
المدن القوات النخبه تستنزف لانها هي
الوحيده القادره على الهجوم ماذا عن بعد
هل سيكون تعب هل سيكون هناك قدره لمتابعه
هذا الهجوم نعم فيما يتعلق بالتحركات في
شمال اوكرانيا تحديدا في بيلاروسيا ما
الذي تقراه فيها هل يمكن بالفعل ان تفتح
جبهه جديده
اول لفتح جبهه جديده يجب ان يكون هناك
منظومه عسكريه كامله متكامله من قوات
كومباين كما يقال مشتركه من مدفعيه من
طيران من صواريخ وحتى من
حتى المستشفيات الميدانيه حتى الان هناك
التدريبات البسيطه حتى الان يبدو انه في
مدينه
في شمال اا بلا روسيا وهي تبعد تقريبا عن
كيف 550 كيلو متر همم هناك ما يقارب
1400 جندي روسي ليست كافيه اليوم نتحدث عن
حدود مشتركه اكثر من 1,000 كم هل يمكن
الذهاب بحرب اشتياح والبقاء والاحتلال
وشاهدنا انه مدينه محمود حتى الان منذ سته
اشهر لم تسقط يعني اليوم الهدف دائما هو
الردع هذا ما قاله وزير الدفاع ال همم
وزير هي الروسي الربع وتثبيت بعض القوى
الاوكرانيه في هذه الجبهه لعدم استعمالها
بمكان اخر حتى الان لا اعتقد ان هناك شيء
سريع قريب لهجوم همم على اوكرانيا عميد
لياسر ما الرساله التي يريد ارسالها
الناتو من وراء النقل انظمه الايه واكس من
المانيا الى رومانيا
السي اليوم بعد ان بدات الحرب باوكرانيا
زاد عدد الجيش الامريكي في اوروبا همم من
السلاح جو من سلاح بحري من غواصات ومن
سلاح سيبراني الى ما يقارب 100,000 جندي
يعني اليوم 14 ايه واكس موجوده في المانيا
سينشر منها ثلاثه مع دوريات مستمره وكامله
نشر الخبر هو استمرار لشيء معين ولكن نبقى
دائما ضمن النطاق الدول التابعه للنيتو
ليس ضمن اوكرانيا هذا الامر يؤدي الى مزيد
من الردع وان امريكا تراقب من فوق كما
يقاله اي اند سكاي لاي واكس لكن هو هو
السؤال عن رد الفعل الروسي على هذه الخطوه
كيف يمكن ان يكون
اولا الرد الفعلي الطائرات هي فوق دوله
ذات سياده من حلف الناتو ليس ضمن اوكرانيا
وسلام وشاهدنا ولاحظنا خلال فترات الحرب
منذ 24 شباط الماضي 2022 وحتى الان هناك
قدم للخطوط الحمراء التي وضعها الرئيس
بوتين اولا بدانا بالجافلين بعدها انتقلنا
الى الهاي مارس اليوم ننتقل الى الدبابات
وبالتالي البتريوت وكانه هذا الامر متدحرج
القدمه التدريجي للخطوط الحمراء للروسيه
شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي